gta 5 is getting another new coat of
paint thanks to mods pokemon scarlet and
violet get new battle details and the
game awards has an official date
the mod scene for gta 5 has been very
exciting ever since the game first
released on pc just over seven years ago
and it's no surprise that it is still
going strong so there's no better way to
pretend you're playing a new gta than to
add great mods to the current game while
you patiently wait for six to arrive
natural vision is a long-running visual
enhancement mod for gta 5. the mod
originally got a full release under the
name natural vision remastered but
development has continued under the
moniker natural vision evolved in a new
trailer the team behind it shows off
their work and outlines recent additions
to the mod this latest update adds
parallax roads pavements and building
interiors giving the ground more layered
textures and granting inaccessible
interiors the illusion of depth a wide a
variety of vegetation and volumetric
clouds lend additional fidelity to the
game's natural landscapes finally this
update overhauls lighting and adds
animated signs to the game the mod is
also fully compatible with 5m a popular
multiplayer modification this mod has
yet to have a full release but is in
early access beta so you can download it
for free on the raised mods website
switching gears now to a franchise that
i wish could get visual enhancements on
pc pokemon at the conclusion of the 2022
pokemon world championships in london
the pokemon company revealed a new
trailer for pokemon scarlet and violet
which focused on battle mechanics and
online play the trailer opened up with
the introduction of a new pokemon the
dragon and normal type cyclizer which
showed off a new move called shred tail
this move acts as a mixture of
substitute in baton pass creating a
pokedoll substitute before immediately
swapping out for another pokemon in the
party the trailer also showed off new
battle items coming to pokemon scarlet
and violet including the mirror herb
which mimics a snap boost an opponent
gives itself and applies it to the
holder of the item another item is
loaded dice which makes multi-hit
attacks have a higher chance of landing
the maximum number of hits along with
the new trailer the website also
detailed the all-new battle stadium mode
which acts as the game's online battle
feature both casual and ranked battles
will be included from launch while
friendly and official online competitive
options will also be available players
will be able to build a team for battle
and then share its unique id allowing
anyone with the id to use that team as a
rental now moving right along to this
year's game awards after a 2021 event
that saw the highest streaming numbers
in its history jeff keeley will present
the 2022 game awards on december 8th
live from los angeles the ninth annual
game awards will be broadcast live on
over 40 streaming services around the
world but you'll only have to worry
about two of them because we'll be
broadcasting the event right here at
gamespot via our youtube and twitch
channels this year will also mark the
return of public ticket sales to the
ceremony pending health and safety
guidelines from both the cdc and the
city of los angeles alongside an
official date a brand new award has also
been confirmed for the ceremony best
adaptation which will recognize movies
tv shows podcasts and other forms of
media that adapt a video game ip but
december is still a ways away so in the
meantime make sure to catch jeff
keeley's next event gamescom opening
night live which we'll broadcast
tomorrow at 11 a.m pacific 2 p.m eastern
right here on gamespots youtube and
twitch channels we'll see you then
[Music]
you